[Musik]
weiter hohe krone zahlen der
bundesgesundheitsminister sieht aber
fortschritte beim impfen
prominente schauspieler sorgen mit einer
protestaktion für diskussionen
heikler termin für angela merkel als
zeugin im wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss verteidigt die
kanzlerin ihren einsatz für das skandal
unternehmen münchen bleibt spielort der
fußball wm
ob und wie viele fans im sommer dann ins
stadion dürfen ist noch offen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers abend hinein die welt
an diesem freitag mit katja stresow für
den sport einen schönen guten ab der
jetzt kommenden nacht gilt in weiten
teilen deutschlands die sogenannte
bundes notbremse mit nächtlichen
ausgangs beschränkungen die auch für
privatreisende gelten wie die situation
beim impfen aktuell ist dazu gab es
heute fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister und das robert
koch institut die wissenschaftler dort
warten und erklärten aber auch dass ihre
schlimmsten befürchtungen nicht
eingetreten sind
heike slansky eine gute nachricht heute
aus der bundespressekonferenz zur lage
der pandemie die prognose des rk ii vor
ostern ist so nicht eingetreten der
inzidenz wert liegt nicht wie befürchtet
über 300 sondern bei gut 160 die weiter
ansteigende moment nicht mehr so rasant
anzusteigen
das ist nur eine gute nachricht ein
grund laut lka weniger mobilität an den
ostertagen und so das leben durch
letztendlich die warnung die wenn damit
aussprechen auch ich verhalten verändert
beim impfen hat
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen die
erwartungen etwas gedämpft stellte klar
was er mit der voraussichtlichen
aufhebung der priorisierung im juni
meinte das heißt nicht dass wir dann im
juni schon alle impfen können
sondern das wird natürlich dann auch bis
in den sommer hinein gehen müssen laut
bundesgesundheitsministerium sind
zurzeit 18 5 millionen bürger zum ersten
mal geimpft rund 22 prozent den vollen
schutz also die zweite impfung haben 5,7
millionen erhalten demnächst auch mit
johnson johnson
wir freuen uns auf ihr hochwirksame
zugelassene impfstoffe auch der kunde
ist sehr sicher 80 prozent wirksam
die dritte welle lässt sich jedoch weder
weg impfen noch weg testen so sparen
deshalb gelte nach wie vor die devise
solidarisch kontakte zu reduzieren die
gestern erst verabschiedete notbremse
ist seiner ansicht nach hat aber nötig
dann schauen wir jetzt so ein bisschen
nach vorn mit chakuza banerjee in berlin
statt und am montag gibt es einen neuen
gipfel zum impfen mit den länder
chefinnen und chefs und der
bundeskanzlerin was ist denn da zu
erwarten was dann künftig für geimpfte
gelten soll
ja da haben bund und länder ein thema
vor der brust das noch für ordentlich
spannung sorgen kann in den kommenden
monaten ihren sparen hat zwar heute
schon gesagt man ist schon dabei sich
vorzubereiten darauf die
einreisebestimmungen zum beispiel für
geimpfte anzupassen aber noch stehen
mehr fragen auf der tagesordnung als
antworten zum beispiel die wie man mit
vollständigen vollständig geimpften im
vergleich zu negativ getesteten umgeht
bekommen die dann dieselben rechte
dürfen dann auch einfach einkaufen gehen
zum beispiel oder sich die haare
schneiden lassen oder wie sieht es aus
mit den vorschriften die man momentan
noch für alle gültig hat nämlich
ausgangssperren oder kontakt
beschränkungen darf man die auch noch
denjenigen machen die vollständig
geimpft sind das sind schwierige fragen
und da ist auch noch nicht ganz klar ob
man sich am montag da wird
auseinandersetzen können und ein zu
einem ergebnis kommen kann ganz offen
ist noch die frage wie geht man mit
kindern und jugendlichen um die er auf
monate hinaus wahrscheinlich noch keine
geeignete impfung bekommen können am
montag beginnen da erstmals die
beratungen zwischen bund und ländern und
jens spahn hat heute schon mal gesagt
ein ergebnis kann er da noch nicht
versprechen
dankeschön nach berlin und dann schauen
wir jetzt auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen die das robert koch institut
heute meldet
innerhalb von 24 stunden wurden dem rk
ii 27 1543 neuinfektionen gemeldet das
sind 1712 mehr als am vergangenen
freitag 265 todesfälle kamen dazu die
sieben tage inzidenz steigt auf 164 in
dieser lage sorgen jetzt mehr als 50
bekannte schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler für große diskussionen
darunter jan josef liefers nadja uhl
ulrike folkerts volker bruch unter dem
motto alles dichtmachen veröffentlichten
sie kurze videos da geht es satirisch
zynisch um politik in der pandemie
maßnahmen medien die reaktionen
unverständnis aber auch applaus der so
zum teil wohl nicht gewollt war volker
jescheck berichtet von vielen geliebt
von mindestens zu vielen abgelehnt die
ironisch satirischer ab richtung der
schauspieler mit der korona politik der
bundesregierung die video aktion hashtag
alles dichtmachen von tv stars wie jan
josef liefers polarisiert wir sollten
einfach nur allem zustimmen und tun was
man uns sagt nur so kommen wir gut durch
die pandemie
wir haben sie gesund verzweifeln sie
ruhig aber zweifeln sie nicht
und auch kollege richy müller macht sich
öffentlich sorgen künstler wie igor
levit halten die aktion für falsch sie
werde den opfern der partie nicht
gerecht sachliche kritik ja aber keine
pauschale medienkritik meint er pianist
ein auf gleichgeschaltete medien und hh
und
das ist keine kritik das spaltet es
führt so gar nichts ist hilft vor allen
dingen niemandem
die künstler bekommen bei fall aus
gruppen mit denen viele nach eigenen
angaben überhaupt nicht sympathisieren
alice seidel von der afg spendet applaus
hans-georg maßen ex
verfassungsschutzpräsident nennt die
aktion großartig
ulrich matthes ist einer der
international bekanntesten deutschen
schauspieler erhält die aktion für
falsch und sie liefert was ich besonders
fatal finde
schützenhilfe für die gesamte querdenker
szene und die afg die sicher zum teil in
den sozialen netzwerken begeistert
darüber äußern
nachdem shitstorm in den sozialen medien
sind viele schauspieler sprachlos und
geben vorerst keine interviews mehr
einige haben ihre videos zurückgezogen
die aufregung im netz hält an
das thema auch gleich bei zdf heute live
zum mitdiskutieren auch via facebook und
youtube und die regeln zur neuen
bundesweiten corona notbremse gibt es
ausführlich nachzulesen in der zdf-
heute- app unter anderem antworten auf
die fragen was da wo genau gilt und
welche bußgelder drohen dass der staat
die wirtschaftlichen folgen der korona
krise weiter abfedern kann dafür hat der
bundestag heute den weg frei gemacht mit
der mehrheit von union und spd
verabschiedete er den nachtragshaushalt
von 60,4 milliarden euro
damit kann der bund in diesem jahr bis
zu 240 milliarden euro neue schulden
machen
unser nächstes thema jetzt wieder ein
wichtiger tag im wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestages
heute mit der bundeskanzlerin als
vorerst letzte zeugin unter den
politisch verantwortlichen angela merkel
musste diverse fragen beantworten vor
allem zu ihrer china reise im september
2009 10
dort hatte sie sich für wirecard stark
gemacht obwohl es schon berichte gab
über die schieflage des unternehmens als
lobbyist für wirecard knüpfte damals
karl theodor zu guttenberg die kontakte
ins kanzleramt
aus berlin berichtet florian neumann
der sechste untersuchungsausschuss dem
angela merkel in ihrer kanzlerschaft
rede und antwort stehen muss ist einer
der erfolgreichsten in wenigen monaten
hat der wirecard untersuchungsausschuss
flächendeckendes kontrollversagen
offengelegt und nebenbei für diverse
rücktritte oder entlassungen gesorgt ob
an der spitze der finanzaufsicht bafin
der wirtschaftsprüfer auf sich tapas
oder der prüfstelle für rechnungslegung
dpr angela merkels job ist heute nicht
in gefahr ihr ansehen vielleicht schon
im september 2009 10 nämlich warb merkel
persönlich für das unternehmen in china
zwei tage vorher noch hatte sie sich mit
ex minister karl theodor zu guttenberg
getroffen der seine kontakte damals für
wirecard zu geld machte es ist wirecard
gelungen einen bezahlten lobbyisten mit
direkten gesprächskontakt zur
bundeskanzlerin direkt vor abflug der
bundeskanzlerin nach china ins
kanzleramt zu bringen die kanzlerin hat
sich von ihm dazu bringen lassen in
wirecard in china für wirecard zu werben
merkel will keinen fehler erkennen mit
dem damaligen wissen sei der einsatz für
wirecard richtig gewesen von
wirtschaftsprüfern bis zur
finanzaufsicht auf der fachebene wurden
viele zur verantwortung gezogen in
diesem skandal nur auf die frage nach
der politischen verantwortung für das
kontrollversagen erhielt der
untersuchungsausschuss keine antwort
weder vom finanzminister noch von der
kanzlerin auch ehemalige minister zu
treffen sagt merkel sei
selbstverständlich doch selbst csu
parteifreunden ist der einsatz von zu
guttenberg peinlich es gibt dinge die
tut man einfach nicht nämlich sich bei
der kunst bundeskanzlerin für eigene
geschäfte einzusetzen und deshalb habe
ich mich für meine partei entschuldigt
weil nicht das sehr berührt hat
es bleibt die einzige entschuldigung an
diesem tag und damit in dieser sendung
ins ausland 24 tage lang war der
inhaftierte kreml-kritiker alexej
nawalny im hungerstreik
jetzt hat er angekündigt langsam wieder
nahrung zu sich nehmen zu wollen
ärzte hätten ihm gewarnt dass er
ansonsten sterben könnte navalny wollte
mit dem hungerstreik erreichen dass
seine ärzte ihn wegen starker
rückenschmerzen behandeln an dieser
forderung halte er fest sagt navalny
heute und wir bleiben in der region
russland hatte mit der stationierung von
zehntausenden soldaten an der grenze zur
ukraine besorgnis ausgelöst
jetzt beginnt der kreml damit truppen
wieder abzuziehen
das manöver sei beendet doch in der
ukraine bleiben zweifel zu massiv war
der aufmarsch des russischen militärs
auf der krim und im grenzgebiet nahe der
umkämpften ost ukraine christian selben
berichtet kommando zurück all die panzer
kriegsschiffe militärfahrzeuge und
zehntausende soldaten sollen wieder an
ihrer ursprünglichen standorte abzug von
der russischen grenze zur ukraine und
von der besetzten halbinsel krim
die übung sei beendet heißt es in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew heute
vorsichtiger erleichterung
ich denke dass sie präsidenten putin und
sie lenski weise genug sind damit der
krieg nicht beginnt wenn sie die truppen
abgezogen haben ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines krieges
geringer
doch was hatte russland zum ziel als es
in den letzten wochen im großen stil
sein militär an der ukrainischen grenze
und auf der krim zusammenzog offiziell
zu einem manöver aber angst machte sich
breit in europa der konflikt in der ost
ukraine könnte wieder auflaufen
es wurde alles getan um so viel
aufmerksamkeit wie möglich auf diese
operation zu lenken und die mögliche
anzahl von truppen zu maximieren und all
das deutet darauf hin dass es sich um
eine machtdemonstration gehandelt hat
ein säbelrasseln das schnell eskalieren
kann denn der konflikt in der ost
ukraine bleibt ungelöst
anna wacker lebt mit ihren kindern in
afrika direkt an der frontlinie
sie bleibt skeptisch auch nach dem
russischen truppenrückzug es ist uns
egal worauf sie sich einigen wir wollen
ruhe und frieden endlich wieder frei
atmen können ohne ständig zu fürchten
dass man unter beschuss gerät
das misstrauen bleibt nicht nur bei an
warten wir ab sagt sie hauptsache der
krieg beginnen nicht von neuem in der
nähe von paris ist eine polizistin nach
einem messerangriff in der polizeiwache
gestorben
die behörden vermuten einen terrorakt
bei dem tatverdächtigen soll es sich um
einen 36 jährigen tunesier handeln er
wurde von einem polizisten angeschossen
und starb an seinen verletzungen
die katholische kirche und wie sie die
missbrauchsvorwürfe aufarbeitet kritiker
sagen zu wenig transparent und viel zu
langsam
natürlich steht das thema auch im
mittelpunkt der frühjahrsversammlung der
katholischen laien also von denen die
kein geistliches amt innehaben und sich
denn auch um ihre kirche sorgen dort
ferber seit fünf wochen kennen sie das
missbrauchs gutachten ihres erzbistums
köln
seit fünf wochen debattieren sie was
muss anders werden in ihrer kirche wir
haben keine ruhe sorgen dass es brodelt
noch an der basis nicht erwarte einfach
eine offene diskussion über die ursachen
des missbrauchs und die wird irgendwann
kardinal leider abgelehnt
es werden menschen ausgetauscht
also im moment sind sie ja nur
suspendiert sozusagen aber davon haben
wir noch keine struktur verändert nach
dem missbrauchs gutachten in köln fragen
sie sich wie geht es nun weiter mit der
aufarbeitung der sexualisierten gewalt
es knirscht noch immer in köln heißt es
aus dem diözesanrat dort dabei sind die
erwartungen ganz eindeutig sagen die
katholischen laien
wir erwarten dass wir diese aufarbeitung
nicht als etwas begreifen wo man
irgendwie so einen nebenbei thema
abräumt sondern dass wir das begreifen
als eine wirklich fundamentale krise der
kirche auf der frühjahrs vollversammlung
des zentralkomitees der katholiken
spielt die aufarbeitung eine große rolle
auch in den eigenen reihen etwa bei der
jugendarbeit wo haben wir als laien
mitgewirkt wo haben wir eine vertuschung
mitgeboten haben wir auch selber
missbrauch ausgeübt was ist in unserer
gemeinde passiert in unserem verbänden
treten die laien wollen nun vorangehen
und aufklären sie wollen ihre
verantwortung wahrnehmen
mit jeder weiteren stunde schwindet die
hoffnung dass die 53 seeleute an bord
eines vermissten indonesischen u boots
noch zu retten sind noch immer ist
unklar wo genau das u boot liegt
vermutet wird es vor bali und es gibt
keinen kontakt zur u boot crew
indonesien hat die suche per schiff und
flugzeug verstärkt es ist ein wettlauf
gegen die zeit normen odenthal
indonesiens marine fährt auf was sie hat
denn für das vermisste u-boot drängt die
zeit der sauerstoff reicht noch für
höchstens drei stunden wenn die
berechnungen stimmen
es gibt verschiedene phasen und bot
gesuchte boot vermisst u boot verloren
ich hoffe sehr dass wir noch in der u
boot vermisst phase sind ich will nicht
spekulieren bis morgen früh 3 uhr
ortszeit versuchen wir alles rund 100
kilometer nördlich von bani wird das
boot vermutet die meerestiefe liegt hier
jedoch bei bis zu 700 metern
das boot soll höchstens 500 aushalten 53
seemänner sind an bord einer gala 402
ein deutsches fabrikat baujahr etwa 1980
1400 tonnen schwer
mangala 402 sei in einem einwandfreien
zustand gewesen sagt die marine und
rätselt was passiert ist
doch jetzt zählt erst einmal nur suchen
und finden indonesiens oberster militär
versucht mut zur hoffentlich geht es
unserer familie den soldaten auf mandala
402 und hoffentlich finden wir sie bald
sei tapfer bis zuletzt aus der luft sei
ein ölfleck entdeckt worden hieß es
inzwischen und ein großes metallisches
objekt in 100 metern tiefe
mehr ist nicht bekannt aber man klammert
sich an jeden hoffnungsschimmer
heute startete der dritte bemanntes
spacex flug zur internationalen
raumstation
erstmals ist auch ein europäer mit dabei
am morgen ob die hob die trägerrakete
vom weltraumbahnhof cape canaveral ab
dass private unternehmen spacex setzt
wiederaufbereitete raketen und kapseln 1
der französische esa-astronaut tomate
und die anderen crewmitglieder sollen
ein halbes jahr auf der iss bleiben und
damit zurück auf die erde und zu katja
ott im sport und durchatmen in münchen
der münchen bleibt spielort der fußball
europameisterschaft in diesem sommer
auch wenn die bayerische
landeshauptstadt keine garantie für
zuschauer im stadion geben konnte
bestätigte das exekutivkomitee der uefa
münchen als gastgeber für vier em spiele
so voll wie früher wird es nicht werden
bei den drei deutschen gruppenspielen
und dem viertelfinale
die uefa erwartet aber mindestens 14
eineinhalb tausend fans im münchner
stadion spiele mit dieser zuschauerzahl
hätten die zuständigen behörden
genehmigt heißt es bei europas fußball
verband von solchen garantien will man
in münchen nichts wissen ob es
vor zuschauern ist und vor wie vielen
konnte ich schon vor einer woche nicht
sagen kann auch heute niemand sagen
deswegen gab es auch bis zum heutigen
tag keine zusagen irgendwelcher
zuschauer garantien es wird erst vom
infektionsgeschehen abhängig gemacht
werden können ob die möglichkeit besteht
zuschauer ins stadion einzulassen oder
nicht während geisterspiele in münchen
demnach möglich bleiben wurde der
spielort dublin von der uefa gestrichen
die irische regierung konnte nicht
zusichern dass das stadion wie gefordert
zu einem viertel gefüllt ist die erste
paneuropäische fußball em findet damit
in 11 ländern statt
zum tennis angelique kerber ist beim
wta-turnier in stuttgart als letzte
deutsche in achtelfinale ausgeschieden
die nummer 26 der welt verlor gegen die
nummer fünf der welt die ukrainerin
elenas vito li na mit 6 7 und 3 6
diese platzierung ist doch wunderbar
sagte turnerin elisabeth seitz über
ihren fünften platz bei den
europameisterschaften in basel in der
schweiz im mehrkampf finale lief vieles
gut aber eben noch nicht alles perfekt
wie sich das eben für eine gute
generalprobe gehört im ganzkörperanzug
einem statement gegen sexismus im
turnsport zeigte elisabeth seitz einen
starken mehrkampf im finale drei monate
vor den olympischen spielen
besonders an ihrem paradegerät dem
stufenbarren konnte sie überzeugen vor
drei jahren bei der wm in doha gewann
sie bronze an diesem gerät und holte
heute 14 033 punkte eine gute grundlage
für die folgenden drei disziplinen eine
medaille wurde es nicht aber rang fünf
ein sehr gutes ergebnis auch
teamkollegin kim bui gelangen ein
starker siebter platz im mehrkampf
aber morgen kann elisabeth seitz gold
holen am stufenbarren im einzelfinale
wir sind gespannt katja vielen dank
gerne und wir sind mitten im frühling
wer daran noch zweifel hat für den gibt
es jetzt diese bilder 13.000 tulpen
kaiserkronen hier zinsen 20.000
frühlingsblumen viola goldlack
vergissmeinnicht seit heute zu sehen in
erfurt auf der frisch eröffneten
bundesgartenschau ein blaues band
verbindet die standorte erinnerung an
die erfurter firma die dafür die weit
blau pflanze nutzten insgesamt aber
viele grüne ideen ab jetzt bis anfang
oktober und das wetter passt dazu mit
einem sonne wolken mix mehr hat gleich
osten terry für sie im heute journal hat
die kollegin marietta slomka den blick
auf diesen freitag um 22 uhr und damit
sagen wir danke für heute gerne bis
morgen machen sie sich einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weiterhin haben
wir eine regionale lage das bedeutet die
luft kommt aus dem norden zu uns und so
bleibt es im norden deutschlands
deutlich kühler als im süden schuld
daran ist dieses hoch über dem nordmeer
dass es ziemlich kräftig und bleibt auch
in den nächsten tagen schauen wir uns
die details an über den norden ziehen
einige wolken richtung osten im süden
klar des grösstenteils auf ihr funkeln
die sterne vom himmel und das bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus drei
grad im vogtland und plus 5 grad an der
nordsee morgen soll auf sieht es im
norden ähnlich aus mehr wolken als im
süden aber insgesamt bleibt es trocken
ganz im süden an den alten scheint die
sonne genauso wie an den küsten und die
temperaturen erreichen bis zu 19 grad im
süden deutschlands zahlt 21 im südwesten
sonst liegen die werte bei neun bis 13
grad und die kommenden tage am sonntag
viel sonnenschein vor allem im süden bis
19 grad und ab montag ist es nicht mehr
ganz so mild dienstag kommt sogar etwas
regen dazu damit einen schönen abend